halo 5 Guardians kicked off the
microsoft press conference and they
showed some four player co-op campaign
play showed some trailers what you guys
think I thought it's fantastic boy did a
great job of a halo 5 I think that they
knew that game needed to be different
enough and I think they they emphasize
what was going to be knew about this
game I think with the war zone
multiplayer at the end that they showed
I think that's going to be really
interesting I think the cynic and people
are going to say okay they're adding a
bit of titanfall in there they're adding
bit of Destiny in there but personally I
think they've done a really good job I
think it's looking way more distinct
than previous Halo games it was always
like a common like thread between each
of them where's this feels like 343 kind
of ripping it away from Bungie and
making it of its own halo 4 was a small
step towards up but it still was very
much tied into the old thing but by
pushing most a chief on to the other
side and having a brand new group of
people to kind of look after its really
really interesting I like that I mean we
were reading about the four player co-op
stuff beforehand but I like that we got
to see that in action and it looked
really cool where lock was giving orders
to different people and they were kind
of doing as he was told as they were
told it look really really cool I'm
excited about it it still feels like
halo though because you got meaner than
that that grunt spot was the perfect
hailer spot for me I regret exactly
those adorable it's it still got that I
don't know that that little bit of it to
me like that little bit of humor or that
and plus lots of purple purpose my halo
color purple and yellow so it's both oh
hello and you hit a contrast yeah I
really do like that four player co-op
dynamic they're showing off the banter
reminded me of ODST of reach and those
are some of bungees more personality
driven halos and so I'm definitely
looking forward to those characters
being fleshed out the new Promethean
sort of the hunter hunter killers at the
later reference there I soar to new
Promethean enemies on display here yeah
as well as the Spartan abilities from
the multiplayer beta yeah like we just
saw there is a lot more cooperation
between characters like we saw the one
of the spots reviving another one which
is something new to the series and it is
like it's very similar to stuff like
gears and other co-op based games like I
think and when you're playing on your
own
you can issue a command to one of the AI
characters to go and do it whereas
whether you're playing with an actual
human you can go over and do it yourself
so yeah and there's a bit towards the
end where the actual the main boss enemy
that came up comes up at the ground and
it looks just like destiny so it's like
it felt like a destiny moment there yeah
wow yeah they are kind of drawing from
all of its all the inspirations and were
like where the halo has gone gone on to
become way to become different games
they're taking everything so yeah it is
looking very very cool i like i like the
look of it so far i'm excited for halo
once again after a somewhat tepid
response to halo 4 and halo 5 Guardians
due out this fall I they announce
release date is it an October release
date I belong sonic currently yeah I
think that we can I guess I was just so
hyped by I didn't get I was just rolling
off my chair October 27th halo 5
guardians